are you ready I am ready one I'm just
gonna Yelp go okay okay
go oh my god who rubbed my left I rubbed
your lamp
hey sir it wasn't him I'm a known rubber
but I don't want to do any of that
hey Phil I knew that was bad luck when
you told me to rub that lamp I know
there's this giant magic sea monster on
you all that genie I'm called a team all
the 13e you idiot have you seen Aladdin
sing same principle but he said Phil he
said you told him to rub it I can only
give the wishes to whoever rubbed it
this is like the crucially important
steps by Fonzie I get a wish I want yeah
make them shorter than me look for six
years you don't mind man named John I
want to be taller than no make them
shorter than me don't make me taller I'm
good where I am but make them shorter
I'm sure you don't want taller I want
you to be shorter he can't even you to
be shorter you're out of time 15 seconds
go Hiroshima start a teeny part of
knowing rubber I rub you so good I
rubbed I rub big you shorten I get in
the lamp one second okay ready set go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]